مع انتقال كرستيانو رونالدو وعائلته الى
الرياض الانضمام الى نادي النصر لا حديث
للناس الا ما قر اقامته والحي الذي سيعيش
فيه والمدرسه التي ستستقبل اولاده
المعلومات المتداوله الاعلام
وعائلته في حي المحمديه او في حي النخيل
المجاور له الشمال غرب الرياض
يتم تجهيز مكان اقامته في الرياض المرشح
بشكل كبير هذا الحي الذي نتواجد به حي
المحمديه الذي يحتوي على العديد من القصور
في الحقيقه هذا المشهد الطبيعي لهذا الحي
العديد من القصور عديد من البيوت ذات
المساحات الشاشه
العالي للخدمه الاساسيه والمرافق مثل
المدارس الاجنبيه والمقرات الحكوميه
والمستشفيات
ومن اهم المزايا التوافر ميقات جذب فيهما
او بالقرب منهما مثل وادي زون اضافه الى
وجود جامعه الملك سعود بمحاداتهما
يعطيكم فكره عن اسعار العقارات في حي
المحمديه
بحسب بعض الخبراء ومن استطلاعنا للعقارات
المعروضه على التطبيقات العقاريه يقدر
متوسط اسعار ايجار الشقق في الحي ب 60 الف
ريال سنويا فيما يتراوح وسعره مثل الارض
بين خمسه الاف و6000 ريال ويصلوا في بعض
المواقع الى عشره الاف ريال اما اسعار
الفلل المعروضه فتتراوح بين الاربعه ونصف
مليون والثمانيه ملايين يعني
هذا يعني انه من اغلى الاحياء السكنيه في
الرياض لكن حين نتحدث عن قصر رونالدو فنحن
نتحدث عن مستوى اخر من العقارات الفاخره
فهل يؤدي انتقال نجم البرتغالي للسكن في
حي المحمديه الى ارتفاع اكبر للاسعار فيه
كبير جدا يدور في الوسط العقاري اهم مدى
تاثر اسعار حي المحمديه او حي النخيل بعد
ان يقطن فيه اللاعب العالمي كريستيانو
رونالدو طبعا الجواب بكل تاكيد لا لا يوجد
هناك اكثر همم بمن سيسكن في هذا الحي من
ناحيه السعر طبعا الذي يحدد السعر والعرض
والطلب فقط اي نعم جار قبل الدار ولكن هذا
لا يعني ان الاسعار سترتفع بانتقال او
اعلان انتقال همم اللاعب العالمي للسكن
فيه